digital marketing is rapidly evolving
and today no marketer can really claim
to be an expert based on their
experience alone
it's the tools they learn the
certificates they earn
and who they earn them from that make
the experience stand out
what if you could get a head start where
many struggle by mastering the latest
tools
strategies frameworks and best practices
in the field in just
six months sitting at home and at a
fraction of any equivalent on-campus
program out there
welcome to our unique postgraduate
program in digital marketing
in partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with facebook
blueprint
and harvard business publishing
deep dive into a top-notch digital
marketing curriculum
covering over 35 in demand tools
learn in a rigorous boot camp
environment offering you work-ready
training in everything from seo
ppc web analytics to content marketing
brand management and much more learn by
doing
experience eight times higher live
interaction with applied learning in a
classroom classroom-like environment
with a cohort of equally driven
professionals like you
from around the world sharpen your
understanding with real-world case
studies
authored by hbs professors and master
classes from faculty at purdue
university
and industry experts from facebook you
also get to perfect the skills as you
learn them through multiple projects
that simulate real marketing problems
and a capstone project in five domains
that you can showcase to future
employers
at the end of it all you walk away with
a globally prized skill set
a purdue simply learn joint postgraduate
program certification
purdue alumni membership and the keys to
the digital marketing success that
awaits you
so are you ready for a digital marketing
career kickstart that very few get
take the next step and fill in a
two-minute application form
our admissions consultant will walk you
through the prerequisites
we hope to see you at the next cohort
you